it takes a certain craziness for people
to go out and pursue these things the
raw destruction of nature in such a
tight enclosed area is it's tragic it's
amazing it's beautiful and everyone for
me it holds that sense of awe and Wonder
here comes my name is tony la Becque and
i'm a storm chaser and meteorologist i
basically make a living out in the field
selling imagery to news outlets telling
the story in a visual sense of what's
happening with with weather from March
to June I'm basically traveling all over
the country in search of severe weather
literally could be putting tens of
thousands of miles on my car sometimes
five thousand miles a week the storm
we've been on is a weakening pretty
pretty handily right now storm coming
out of the south I think has got my
attention right now it's something I'm
kind of watching Kansas has always been
my holy land the flatlands fields the
colors for a normal person you drive
from Kansas City to Colorado and you got
to spend you know eight hours driving
through nothing two chasers to people
like me it's the most beautiful
landscape of anything you can see tens
if not hundreds of miles at a time and
watch these storms from a great distance
it's something truly amazing
we as chasers never ever want storms to
impact anybody in a negative way and
unfortunately in some instances they do
and significantly they they take lives
and and and people's homes and their
livelihoods the lows are devastating but
the highs are amazing because of the
gratification that the beauty everything
that you have put the effort into is
there when you get rewarded by nature
for your efforts and you see this event
in person there's nothing that compares
to that
you